three
ah
oh one hundred
we did we did the amount of
planning that took we get us to
say one hundred the tax year that's
been going you really didn't trust us
on that one by the way you
really didn't i really well to be
fair how many times did you forget
out of the three trade
we would catch on if i forgot
something that you know you go dead
at the once i saw two out
of three people doing it well guess
what everybody it's our one hundredth episode
we fought and scratched and clawed our
way to this top of the podcasting
yeah we yeah who's done one hundred
episode
it's not a lot of people yeah
a lot of people they'll do one
and a half and then in midway
through the first run or the second
one even just say like i quit
and kind of second episode yeah yeah
right in the middle of it and
to be honest i wanted to look
yes i ran out of stuff to
talk about in episode two we know
you've been lying the entire time and
it's impressive by the way like you
did just stuff you could
pull at the top of your head
to make a claim happened to you
maybe it's prophecy and this is not
like experiences from your life it's like
stuff you've read or just stuff you
imagined yeah all sorts of stuff i
recognize one story from a million little
pieces the book
but look one hundred episodes that's nothing
to sneeze at if you did you
shouldn't have done that that's over one
hundred hours of yeah nonsense who bet
against us who bet again what was
the line in vegas e u you
says you're making your the pete rose
podcasting high office getting here did you
think we'd actually
go fifty years yes
do you think we'll get there this
is our fourth you
authorities say it's more years years we
might i don't like actually i would
love to be ninety six years old
still doing the show and will chronicle
everything that's happened in our lives up
until recently i mean i'm definitely going
to be just talking about nothing ninety
six years old for sure no you
don't know
will we be repeating stories we've told
before definitely will we be pretty will
we be rich here's what i say
to you what song is it okay
so i said i know oh okay
yeah it was making me think of
this other song if you want to
be brady the rest of your life
it'll take a man as your wife
it's
mine that pretty nerve is my heart
too broken is that a ram truck
eli talked to ma a rock
a rock okay
see kid you sees you learn wood
using the the star spangled banner at
a dodger game
and do it in that voice i
love you because you have a very
very distinct rockville yeah ik raad really
think it's known um yeah yeah i'd
love to and i would definitely start
laughing again d'arcy carden whom we all
yeah got to throw at the fruit
really put the apostrophe american named darcy
car
and mercy she got to throw out
the first pitch at a pittsburgh pirates
on that oh didn't you she did
very well who's a good pitch she
made it across the plate yes you
did wow he's on the league of
their own oh okay so they've been
working on i'm sure yes and she
she plays a third i think a
third basement in the show i'm not
sure why you gotta throw exam
right right right right so when anyone
else talks about you and use a
ram huh i'm happy that's why i
made that
yeah
recently charged distinctive noise yeah absolutely for
each of our character okay so people
listening in the dark they know who
is mine and we say before every
law
well those too similar
you're just to go oh yes i've
remember this
she she she pitches it to the
mascot who's a parrot pittsburgh parrot oh
huh
but why and he moves a little
ahead of the cassini sounds like pirate
oh it's it's totally my right and
also a pirate not okay no but
pirates have parrots as yeah his little
pill but i wonder the team yes
i wonder if on a pirate ship
they ever get confused they're like hey
parrot i'm sorry i meant pie you
think they're calling you
i think there are pirates do you
think if they did that they would
stop doing it's like oh it does
sound bad do pirates call each other
pirates i know they do in the
yo ho yo ho a pirate's life
for me but are they or are
they just sailors and they're like ok
starring me with that brush oh wow
wait what tarring me with that brush
what happened with the parrot
oh that's his noise
that is for sure what ah so
she the the pie the parrot moved
a little ahead of the plate but
i think she could have gotten it
on the plate it was a good
throw but the announcer introduces her um
and says you know she's she plays
the female third baseman oh totally
league of their own they're all female
yes exact and also she's a woman
yeah suddenly anyone's thinking like if he
said she plays the third baseman in
illegal georgia peaches and a league of
their everyone you know exactly but she's
so weird but i want to retire
see is is very honored that we're
spending so much of our one hundredth
episode or season was real shame i
think he's a big pocket we're going
to talk about every listener by the
way on this episode yes yeah we're
starting with darcy who may or may
not listen but i won't get into
joseph really we know or letters we
assume listen people who listen
in in life oh look he's just
people who actually listen to things yeah
just people who lay people who listen
in lie pay attention are willing to
take criticism already again but we should
also we should talk about our hearing
impaired listeners when they listen in terms
yes in terms of receiving information yes
it will be talking about yes but
the announcer in addition to
giving her female credit um for league
of their own it's a good way
to put it that's the optimistic way
to look at it she got female
credit also said and it sounded like
this she plays janet on a good
place
like it was the craziest thing you'd
ever see first yes first of all
for those really organised yeah that's not
a stumble with somebody fuckin oh a
good er i mean it's not a
good place maybe somebody put an apostrophe
and janet as well yeah janet but
dammit jay and he definitely hadn't read
it before he looked at it and
maybe you can't see that but is
he supposed to be reading every single
thing that comes across his his desk
i would say if you're speaking to
save very little would be prepared at
least read it how many paired are
you ah right now i'm not reading
something i can just spit from the
cuff yeah
i don't know that you can ah
after hearing that i was going to
be speaking into my throat in front
of a stadium of people i would
read it one said you're reading this
right now hey talk here's the thing
would at least have what if he
doesn't give a shit all the dads
already that's what it sounded like because
all he has to do is read
the batting order of the team yeah
and it's like the juicy that happened
i'm sure you get paid i think
it's like three hundred million dollars i
want this with this jaw the stadium
announcer for the pittsburgh pirates three hundred
million dollars a game pits okay yeah
you're good yearly i have to say
i'm glad their mascot isn't a pirate
because that would be dumb well i
think the weekend time they went to
canoes with the players with me
because it's like yeah yeah he just
people being like hey pirates
oh hira hey come on out to
the field people are but then he
would also be ah all of you
pirates come on that's what i'm saying
it got too confusing like the mascot
was always coming out no but he
should come out whereas he's supposed to
be just in the dugout he's up
in the stands is me like company
but man he's he's own tree to
the sciences the field isn't written that's
how
yeah up there yeah i'm sure yes
i thought they were like combs like
phantom billion opera there's gotta know but
isn't it like he should be coming
up like everyone sees him coming like
he walks right up but everyone's like
yay yes that's why they changed it
from a pirate because people were like
my booty
i just mean if he's coming from
the field into the stands it's like
you want to see him enter yeah
exactly it doesn't pop up from behind
but i think he does do that
for fun too
whatever welcome to the show by over
a week should we introduce ourselves yeah
i got a fit bit oh i
want to talk about this is i
got a fitbit yeah she's one of
the host to the shaman starting with
episode one hundred i guess keep it
okay this is lauren laugh guess she's
got a new segment i got a
fitbit yeah
we also have paul f tompkins just
got a new segment a little later
that is going to be really oh
yeah and then i have i have
old segment so i'm gonna do i'm
gonna do lawrence topics but you know
every segment yeah was my old segment
does anybody remember did you have a
segment i think a segment i can
remember when you had it wasn't about
your family
oh but you're familiar see what about
the mgm's challenge was out your segment
it was like i kind of shepherded
that segment yeah just like i produced
it that was a great segment it
was great i was looking for the
allusion to another taste test yeah what
should not being equally tasty how about
this peanut that's right in front of
me what does yeah yeah i don't
know
what is powerless oh it's a cash
i don't give a shit are you
from earth what about this peanut sauce
peanut what is it an element it's
a cashew if anyone don't say all
nuts look exactly the same they don't
and that dog
okay exactly the same except a slightly
crazy chunkier well yeah walnuts look different
crazy chunky that's why they're in the
chunky candy bar with raisins blue walnuts
or another but i just i defy
you are and candy bars i defy
you to put a peanut how can
you find me if you which i'm
sorry you're telling me you think i
been
so does the peanut next to a
cashew if what okay shape like a
sea lion filling up the word that
it is fun and blind the nut
blindfold the blindfold that i still could
taste the difference if you knew what
your tasting
yeah see that's not part of what
you're talking about scott ackerman peanuts taste
different than cashews i'm often because she's
a creamy i introduce you already in
any case you also that's introduced herself
was then you didn't do it well
because we got derailed can you believe
it this is the sound of the
cashew
here really fall into that okay so
tell us about your fitbit
i got a fitbit yesterday okay so
this is really new um pretty new
and i'm really excited about and everyone
in the world knows about these except
for me and i was influenced by
two people i know one or two
influencers one is it on instagram ashley
tisdale was posting motor fitbit and i
got into it yeah and then my
friend danielle fishel and i do workouts
on zoom
gether yeah really yes so what trainer
with a trainer oh and the trainers
also ones had babies recently so we
were doing this together yes the trainers
also i'm so many did you have
i had one how many shell said
one okay so two two babies had
one yeah um why did you decide
to go fitbit as opposed to apple
watch well mike has an apple watch
we cannot find it
so it's somewhere in the house even
with wine maya it's fine i'll find
my watch i don't know if we've
tried that did he ever like it's
still in the bag i'm no no
he's had it forever but he never
was wearing that i was like i
wanna start wearing it and then we
couldn't find it and i say yes
it's probably so just on principle you're
like i'm not buying another watch because
yours is dead in the house somewhere
i wouldn't buy an apple
watch it felt like too many things
i didn't really want to connect what
they want to sponsor us well i
will do it for that but it
connects my phone i didn't know it
was going to and when you are
calling when i was on the phone
it was buzzing and saying for the
phone with paul that's so you're on
the phone with paul f tompkins tells
me how many steps i take and
i really
i'm excited about this how many do
you know how many have you know
you've got it one day we have
you talked about steps before yes and
you guys were incredulous at the idea
of doing ten thousand steps yeah it's
too much okay yankees during the pandemic
it's too much but let me tell
you something i know i agree with
you but let me tell you something
the one day i went to the
office i got ten thousand right okay
listen so ashley walk there had a
baby as well and so she was
her trainer has run a thing with
her fitbit where she's supposed to take
fourteen thousand steps a day now i
saw that and i thought that's insane
that i do two steps a day
there's no way right by mike wonder
for example ah i sit in a
swivel chair between them but it is
what time
two thirty i've taken two thousand and
six hundred and thirty eight steps today
just going around my house yeah you're
never gonna make ten thousand i am
if i go for a walk if
you go for a walk well that's
the thing is i am on the
peloton and that doesn't count towards it
yeah could you get off that were
tyler john is biking sorry not trying
to work out while we're working i
need to see how cody's doing thanking
doesn't
counter steps that was what i'm saying
but it's like just like i'm i'm
exercising i'm just not doing the steps
right but you know this thing also
tracks my exercise and i met some
exercise goal i didn't know i had
okay so anyway
it also tracks my sleep that's what
i'm also interested in because in my
tracks my sleep as well when do
you charge it um i don't know
i haven't i haven't only had a
today
okay you got it yesterday so attract
your sleep last night yeah how was
it doing battery wise right now i'm
at a solid
boy fifty eight percent oh no
yeah my last year i lost ten
days apple watch it's neither because it's
hard to explain but anyway because he
can't say that i've already done nine
thousand seven hundred and sixty two steps
wow
i went to the gymnasium in the
morning there you go i did my
workout with this too but it's all
in my room by the way we
are overwritten lawrence were over at lauren
studio so yeah yes first time this
is exciting first sighting also we have
no i've never seen one in here
we're being very bluesy about it we
have not been in the same room
together now in quite a long time
and it's very exciting weirdly i had
to get used
to it i agree i felt weird
can i tell you how many times
i here and i don't like looking
at my billboard in my tummy yeah
i gotta go home i i'm gonna
call my mum i'm i i'm here
and i only have seven hundred and
seventy nine but is that what your
phone is saying because my phone my
phone taken two hundred steps and i'm
like well because i was carrying my
phone during those
moments yeah well i you're saying it
would be more yeah like there's times
where i don't carry my phone where
i also walk around okay i also
was stealing that are not sitting on
the couch for a long long time
because we had a house inspector come
over and i didn't want to disturb
him or going to other senators to
sleep with yeah like inspect this bitch
you presented basically with your middle finger
what do anything
oh hello
but so you've taken seven hundred steps
ah seven hundred and seventy nine yeah
and they want to walk around a
little yeah that's the next we should
do that a two hundred i'd see
that's what that's what gets it doesn't
get you were walking in a circle
yeah does it give you alerts of
like hey every hour it's time to
walk around because i my apple watch
it's time to move or something yeah
yeah i
i had the apple watch for a
while and and it was doing that
while it was editing especially the tv
show the comedy tv show and it
was just you're just never getting up
so it was like every hour really
this one's talking to you throw that
one away grab another one from the
pile
what episode yeah episodes are watching before
the laser disc at the wall
yeah there was like a period of
like eight months where we were using
laser disc in school and i was
like really cool really like like in
high school they were like it was
like records that look like a dvd
um yeah i know what i mean
when they are because they might be
younger than me true i doubt if
there's any listener out there younger than
louie letters youngest was six and she
he said oh that's right yes
back of woodchuck which yeah exactly yeah
filthy woodshop
he loves to fuck up oh hey
that's good he should do that county
big man probably will let's just do
that right now let's let's workshop and
characters okay okay here's what i've been
working on right are dr that's your
noise out of which i don't er
der der der dichter your noise should
be
we should not be able to imitate
it so that we can't get here
soon because yours right
oh huh oh yeah gonna try yeah
oh yeah we can do it too
okay but what's always getting you made
to go to the bank and they
ask you to make a noi yeah
yeah what noise can i make the
numbers no one else can make it
no can't do it
no like a horsey i can't do
it and you're like the the quiet
place yeah yeah like that monster no
just like a movie i wish he
would shut up
i wish you were my fireplace but
shut up
i spent the movie we seen speaking
of of the quiet place woodchucks oh
i just finished watching the show on
netflix called sweet tooth have you seen
this yeah based on the comic wants
me to walk you and i have
another theory that has like a dog
face it there so there's a little
baby he's got a deer face you're
okay there's all these high
hybrids born behind so they put makeup
or maybe cg all these babies to
think like humans and i heard they
put them through surgery to look at
no little babies they made them have
surgery to look like these animals and
then go but i watched it and
then the paycheck for acting wouldn't even
cover the surgery so they could
nt afford to get changed back did
they even get tapped hard lead though
so that would never be in the
you know they'll never be unionized i
want to ask if you've seen the
goop show
what that is that's the coin of
the new culture when an auto show
where people are having sexual issues in
their relationships and then these sex therapists
like lay they want a table in
there like make them try different things
together lay guy guy guy guy i'm
trying to do that like so like
this one couple is like byway is
this is this what it's about every
ozone ah yes so far i watched
like four and so i think it
is like they sold so many paltrow
is narrowed her brand down to this
it is this is fucking i mean
she has gives out dildo as she
gives out dealing at her like premiere
she gave out tilden um but anyways
they ah lana table and basically there's
this one one couple that's half
being some sort of issue with each
other going back it didn't work when
will you please fill us and watch
us fuck again and then there's like
terrible
it's like handing the man like here
take this chain and drape it over
but why is it but
for sixty bucks or rear in their
anus
or ages older huh
limited with anyway it's pretty intense because
that with your shows about so do
we know does the does the viewer
watch them have sex they don't have
sex but they do stuff like fingering
and stuff whoa so far does your
fingering on show it but you she's
lying down he's up there with your
tea they're just telling he's the ladies
telling him what to do
he's doing it he's doing it are
they finger fucking are finger blasting i
think it was a whole different genre
because we're working on something that they
had not done together finger therapy yeah
it's important
interesting thought about what's what's this on
hbo sa netflix okay i thought wow
how could you possibly be on this
show knowing everyone you know will see
you will not only see your problems
but see you naked and they see
are they actually my problem don't you
show their bodies to some extent yeah
and then see what you're
and then swatch you get it on
with your partner what if they were
wearing like ski masks but other than
that completely nude that i think in
little ski masks on the tip of
their pen like yeah they also would
have because if you saw their penis
you know who was right and they
also like jazz and you know the
gypsy can't hear their them talk yeah
right i have i'm asked hovering
yeah you're right yeah
he noted table ski methods put all
our eggs cucumbers or otherwise in order
to sneak in sept penis has skycap
pierce venus se cab title unidades ask
do you okay to do do do
do do we we have
i feel like we have to take
a break how long have we been
going don't say anything
okay food coolers we go sweet tune
to tune into tooth good i really
have to ally here it's great and
the comic is really there are adorable
the the kids are adorable but there's
also some animals that are more animal
than human and there's one called i
believe name is bobby
who is like some little gopher guy
and yes fucking adorable is it who's
better baby yoda or baby on a
baby origin is the gold standard right
yeah bobby's pretty close i have only
seen one episode of the one with
baby yoda if literally if you if
you there's so much good baby yoda
i know if you had given birth
and i'm
not saying you have but if you
had given birth and the baby happened
to look like baby yoda who we
all think is cute yes but you
would think it's disgusting and you know
what i'd be worried about the origin
or mao no no i think i
think it baby yoda is cute but
well i guess we know what he
looks like when you gets old but
that metal posts not
that's it's grey goo it's not but
i mean he's the same but i
mean there were yeah that's very old
yoda is very old like we're talking
nine hundred years yeah i guess i'd
just be worried about you know teenage
yoda like with a little ice age
mustachio yeah and he has the force
he's got the forest he looks like
alien i'm just saying purely looks like
we think yoda
is so cute and we're like adorable
when we want plushy toys so i'd
be pretty scared if that came out
but pussy yeah one of those c-section
i think we're sad
alright we have to take a break
when we come back we have a
very special yes we know we have
a very we're not doing gas of
course this is threesome but we have
a special view of a special game
but we do have a special guest
you're gonna love it but we have
a special ah version of lawrence topics
so we do yeah okay we gotta
get caught up to some extent to
some extent
and don't forget about my new topic
that's coming in the ride that will
be amazing alright so we'll be right
back with more freedom
wow andre yeah caught on
one hundred one oh one hundred i
got one hundred
welcome back and as promised
time for all of you three adam
hits out there you know that we
hate shit hits that's what our fans
call themselves remember they called themselves shales
here there's a guy i'm a shit
yeah he said on the shithead that
listens to freedom i have an overnight
job and high and mighty fans are
that was cvb world's oh that makes
sense yeah well then no the cvb
world oh okay well sorry
those those people are shitting but what
but but if if you've been tracking
us and our every movement or not
knocking private eyes yeah you know cheating
on you
you know that we haven't seen each
other in person yeah for probably i
would say six months at least six
months yeah we've been longer probably like
summer right we were due at summer
no no no we were doing the
backyard episode last summer it's trawling i
guess i was thinking
like a year ago that you're referring
to no we definitely it was like
march or so i feel like was
the last time we yeah we're one
of these in person that make sense
and we haven't met this past march
yeah did we so yeah yeah oh
say to touch yesterday on the patio
there yeah um patio patio patio yeah
patio so
we didn't know what you meant ah
i really i really didn't understand but
we also ended season three on a
cliffhanger yes and and part of that
was we we taped them all before
a very special event in a young
woman's life happened to lauren for coming
out party her dad presented
her to society
the ladies are wearing long silky gloves
and the gentlemen were retired and their
best tuxedos
so this is time for lawrence topics
and lauren taken away from here and
topics childbirth um i had a baby
childbirth um but which makes me think
of the one hundred collect commercial i
had a baby it's boring we had
okay good but it's a girl um
and so it's the opposite of one
eight hundred collect it's yes
yes it's what's the other one it's
like the evil one eight hundred electrum
oh yeah even the starter guy going
around yeah anyway um yeah i had
a baby it was really intent of
it yeah and and i will say
what's the url know it now like
wow it was it was it what
you expected it to be
where you've fully prepared or did you
get in there and you're like holy
fucking shit this is no it hurt
more than i could ever imagine and
i think the what did it what
did it feel like like if there
was a pain that you could liken
it to i honestly couldn't compare it
to anything it was the most pain
i've ever been in my entire life
really the contractions were extremely painful i
didn't understand
that those would hurt so much you
just thought they would maybe be discomfort
yeah more like like shit didn't happening
or something but it was like i
couldn't even see so i was like
you couldn't see i couldn't open my
eyes i was i had to do
a lot it's different yeah i could
see but i chose not to i
went blind i had a doula and
that is a person you're not familiar
who helps a woman through childbirth and
so it was i didn't want to
get one i honestly i think maybe
it's a midwest like mentality or something
but i just do with my sango
zandt your jacket
xantia your baby coming out of your
i knew i'd never heard of anyone
doing that until i moved here right
and so it felt like a little
unnecessarily cheating it just felt like i
just didn't even know why i would
want that but my friend jonathan silverman
who i worked with on good girls
really convinced me to get a duel
and he helped connect me to somebody
because his wife used one and that
they thought it was just so much
it was so amazing and it really
was because she helped me through the
entire process and so i was like
in a lot of pain but just
having her there kind of like talking
to me and like guiding me in
to shop with the forums um like
paperwork yeah like filling out the but
i did those in advance oh that's
where i would want to do it
like the ten ninety nine yeah you
could you do this for me yeah
that's a taxpayer yeah yeah you gotta
get your baby's taxes all settled don't
deny if your corporation well the contractions
were extremely painful and um i so
i basically was on my feet for
like twelve hours like walking around with
her not able to sit down cause
it felt better to walk
felda said better to what so so
what where were you in the can
can we talk about that where were
you when the first contraction i was
at home i'll never forget where i
was yeah where were you i was
on too
oh i'll never forget what it's called
prodromal labor which is when you go
into labor a bit early promos prodromal
po ro ro romo like too hard
make it something else yeah just make
slowly so early like a week i
was having some contract
tions but just once in a long
while and it wasn't really any so
so the first what like a week
before did you have a first contraction
you're like oh yeah like during the
night i was like oh i think
it's happening and then it just wasn't
i went to sleep and that was
it and that can happen a couple
of times and then um i was
talking to my deluxe i was like
it feels that i was
my baby was born ah eight days
past the due date so yeah at
that point i was i believe i
was wondering what was happening because i
was lying in time yeah it was
sort of like maybe lauren's not announcing
what's going down or i don't know
but i didn't want to check in
and yeah okay some weird was happening
so i'm looking at my calendar then
looking at my phone and
going back and forth yeah every ten
seconds yeah yeah yeah and i fell
asleep standing up
like a bat well yeah like a
bit upside down so she told it
because basically i was like checking in
with her while this was happening over
the weekend she was like the date
like i was i scheduled an induction
because i was like at a certain
point you don't want to go too
far right but there's some cons to
doing inductions too so i was kind
of like not sure if i want
to do it but
i scheduled one and then i the
day before actually went into labor i
called and cancelled my induction because i
was just like i i'm just gonna
wait and that just gonna wait the
day-to-day supposed to do did happen okay
so it was meant to be my
doula told me the day before she's
like go go somewhere take your mind
off it don't think about it because
you're thinking too
you are thinking to have it went
to the grove i went to the
apple store and i got a new
ipad and then they gave me free
your airpods did you call your baby
i-pad or airpods yes and
um that was is their father any
kid out there named i-pad or airpod
for sure please send it send us
the whole team ah covert and corona
kovind corona really corona kind of get
man i remember as a real name
not to not to to essentially too
much fun it's a crown yeah but
corona t-shirts were really popular when i
was in high school like seventeen so
i got one at the local market
i bought it and my parents were
so upset wow sure like beer yeah
it was like
no these are just really popular like
everyone wears them it's like a hard
rock yeah they're like ah
and then you get thrown in the
trash threw it out and they beat
me with a switch they made you
pick it like switch oh weird
this is a big turn the hard
rock cafe was a big deal for
people during the brief amount of weight
around or teacher oh yes yeah because
the t-shirts from all over the collected
yeah yeah now no one gives a
shit yeah so your baby hard rock
cafe yeah is that the name that
is her but yeah beautiful name h
r c
if
wait wait a minute connection oh shit
she's a hard rock cafe
so i went to the grove and
so you're in you're in the the
and i was humble store i was
huge and you were just sticking out
like your the way i looked like
i was about to give birth right
and i got free airpods and i
think it was because of that was
because the guy was like being really
nice feeling gave me free airpods just
ooh and we're sure going
oh my contraction hey let's give them
free air punch case oh for your
butts thank you
ah you're bats
this goes bad i felt bad for
her
it was okay to stomach hurt you
have a good attraction your mama's so
fat sugar free airpods
oh my so yeah i'm a cliche
huh so your ethic grove dude was
at the only place you went there
we went to we also popped over
to silver lake on the way home
and stopped so yeah you go to
the grove yeah only go to the
apple store we will i went to
a couple of other stores because i
was looking for a crib skirt i
had a nesting so it's so mike
doesn't get turned on by the cribs
legs
but no stores had the
yeah so we end but i'm still
cofidis you know so i'm kinda like
zipping in and out of places fountain
did you like i didn't make race
or any trolley know there's no fountain
at the grove but i was very
serious but it wasn't doing shit wasn't
i oh fucking asshole droplets
what about the trolley trolleys gone they're
not probably is not there with just
gonna as they're almost ran me over
what's different day maybe but i did
take i did take highlight to the
americana trying to have a little only
my first americano drew is a nightmare
it was so busy i was like
gotta get out of here but yeah
uh
um anyway so any day i was
at home and i was just up
in the morning would you eat though
the previous day oh good question well
i did get the the salad that's
supposed to induce labor from pizza i
don't know what your name is hey
there's a famous salad that people say
helps induce labor now i ate it
who
does this coyote pizza you know here's
the thing everyone i know who's had
it it has not worked for them
but yeah but it works for you
know because i didn't have today before
i had like a few days oh
okay and that was a lot addressing
you know what's in it that that
would induce oh no they don't tell
you they don't tell you there's a
hidden ingredient but it's basically a drama
like vinaigrette like
a salad huh yeah it's an epidural
yeah it's been epidural juice in there
it really gets things going um and
next day i woke up and i
was just hanging out and then i
started having contractions for sure and it
was really hurt okay and so this
is the more these are like this
is the morning yeah but i didn't
wake mike up because i was i
knew that it would say
sleeps with like five hours later than
you he at the time i was
letting him sleep in because i was
like babies coming high he's gonna be
up all night and i don't want
to wake him up too soon with
this when he's i'm just going to
be sitting here yeah going through this
for a while so i think i
didn't wake him up for do you
think that you would be you it
would be where you prepare you you
thought it was
gonna be a long time before you
went to the hospital yes and my
doula was gonna come to the house
okay and we are going to labor
together at the house because i have
a friend who went into contractions and
and and her husband was like ah
okay let's get you to the hospital
and was kinda like they were both
just taking it easy five-minute trip to
the hospital she
she had the baby like right outside
i mean extremely lucky
nothing does fs was their first baby
no hello that's why oh okay because
it just slipped out further maybe it
takes longer to come out oh these
stories have mentioned the store kit well
hey well until the baby's here okay
delivers the baby so this point i'm
just a lady with a bump so
you waiting for
store your friend show up and the
babies there on the sidewalk for the
hospital yeah that's basically what happened because
the stark couldn't get inside the hospital
i've never heard such because the chimney
was closed someone did close the flue
to the hospitals shut down the chimney
in the hospital with the baby in
a bag
a bag yeah and you have to
say paper or plastic yeah and then
he released the baby teeth yes well
asked me to come into the house
it was getting to be too intense
and by that point mike was awake
and i was sitting on are you
saying like wow i was trying to
watch tv and just know where you're
watching um well if it's funny because
at one point i was watching good
relations so
i was in oh okay so you're
watching yourself on myself my people curious
because i wanted to see the episode
and then i was like this is
ridiculous so i didn't take a picture
of myself because was so stupid but
i was watching that i was watching
some other show that was too intense
oh it was a mayor of east
town okay so horror too intense for
you yeah yeah um just holly knowing
you're on tv
yet she doesn't she hasn't seen a
screen god doesn't understand the concept here
without screens for as long as i
can how long do you think it
alas i would like to go a
full year without her looking at full
year so and so but you're going
to still watch tv because your washer
goop that's right your brain right brain
is formed rank has
his privileges it's my best my opinion
my i and everyone can do it
ever they want and a lot of
people do what the babies you go
a year yeah i think it's fine
i day to i'm going to be
like this is what does just turn
around and watch this i never really
thought much of it until i baby
sat for a woman who ah who
prepped for your new baby settle a
grown wool
woman or child she dressed your bonnet
and she didn't want her baby to
see a screen until she was one
and i so i was never letting
her look at the tv of course
and then kinda didn't think about it
but then i've been i've been reading
up on this and it's there's some
thought college i don't know just wait
a little bit wow do everyone you
find
so obviously we all probably looked at
tv before and we were yeah i
mean i've been watching tv since i
was you and your father die i
think i'm okay that's funny brain hurt
so so what so so you you
the doula came over and you're like
this is getting she didn't get here
i actually i called her and said
meet me they have to just go
yeah too old for this show is
getting too
intense and i thought they won't be
long before i need to leave anyway
so let's just go right and mix
up at this point yeah he's like
and he's excited he's he's excited other
and this is embarrassing at this point
but who is making ah yes so
he's the guy that i live with
roommate oh so he's helping you out
why do you need to do it
if you're running three roommates
why not a doula highly recommend doula
for anyone out there who highly recommended
roommates got a baby coming worth it
because she also she's just very calming
and she helped him to it was
just like she'd kinda told him what
to do the whole time it's great
like this sit down shut up kind
of yeah one point she was like
you need to step away she's getting
really what was he doing he was
trying to help me but i was
starting to annoy but i was being
really nice the whole time i that
should be made very clear that i
was i never stand ever did the
whole there was like a hobby i
was like real does not cause we
have a routine about i don't think
women in labor
i know but i was very nice
the entire time i really firmly believe
that but at certain points she could
tell that i was getting a little
agitated with whatever like i was doing
been rubbing my shoulder oh okay that
was kind of like not right now
like because sometimes that was good and
sometimes it wasn't good right right right
um but yeah and it went on
for hours and hours and then ultimately
so you were in the hospice
all for hours and hours yes the
labor was total it was twelve hours
until she was wow for three hours
of pushing do you know when people
when i would hear that when i
was a kid like i was in
labor for eighteen hours i always pictured
it all happen all taking place in
the hospital yeah but yeah not total
it's like from the moment you start
going to leave
you could be anywhere and that could
do they deal with you i don't
like don't even bother us unless it's
ah or do they say they let
me in because sometimes they want people
to wait go back home because it's
like too soon or something but i
was like unable to walk the second
i got in there but it was
it still took a long time but
does it feel like you need to
take a shit honestly uh
um no it doesn't feel like you
don't think they do say to push
us if you're taking as if i
did not ship by the way i
would like everyone to know okay so
you were nice and you did not
shit yeah which is pretty cool very
good experience nice i'm not sure both
of them would not so so it
feels it doesn't feel like say how
do they fit
raise it when they tell you that
push like you're pooping okay does it
doesn't feel like a kick in the
stomach or just feel like kicking the
really deep within your body and it's
like your whole belly and stomach and
vagina and butt and everything like really
hurts it's like it just hurts so
much i was grabbing the counter like
in pain yeah he's shot
up pain what kind of pain i
get roles in like it was like
i then and they were happening every
couple minutes so i'd have like a
couple minutes of nothing and that's like
oh here comes it's like horror it's
horrible and you still and you still
remember it because they say like if
you ever have a second baby it's
like your mind just will honestly during
it i was thinking how could anyone
do this more than once i i
literally was like this is crazy and
then
later in it i was thinking oh
my god people give birth like in
the woods and they have nobody around
like i don't know what i was
thinking about but i was just like
i like i wish i'm like me
i can do this like i was
just like trying to psych myself um
and then like afterwards i was like
i could do it again it's really
weird really it's like a weird mind
really yeah because you like forget everything
so would you do an epidural
for the second time in why no
epidural the first i was interested in
not using one when i took my
doula because yeah well i just was
like i'm kind of afraid of the
needle going into my spine oh um
but i have a sensitive spine i
was just a little i'd heard a
story that kind of made me nervous
about it oh really and so but
it was just in my head a
little bit but
as a woman who were basically they
if someone i know they did it
wrong and that but she didn't know
that and then she had this headache
that was like insane for days and
then when she finally went back to
the hospital they figured out that it
was like there was a leak or
something yeah she missed the spot basically
i there's a story i heard about
a woman and that's why we're ribbon
around me
yeah you don't want your head to
just fall exactly would yeah anyway so
at a certain point anyway i know
i'm just gonna tell you that i
did say to my doula i'm interested
in that but i can't imagine i
would ever not have an epidural i'm
just curious what like if you didn't
know i mean the first time i
meeting with her and i was like
she asked me like all my opinions
and all these things and i was
like that's intriguing to me but i
don't think of myself as somebody who
avoids medication i can't imagine that i
would do that and it st sounds
really hard now the pain is like
this is what i've heard it's like
if you drop a remote control on
your foot you're just wearing socks
it's like when you step on a
lego and then walk into the foot
of your bed
it's like blocking your shins barking you
never know what if you step on
your bed and then walk into a
logo that would hurt yes step into
your bed and walk like oh no
because the stuff on your bed like
the mattress on your bed and the
bed is lego the bed is laying
love that show
oh that is like i know i've
heard ya
um speaking of the floor is lava
i have a history with that show
wow
why want to reveal reveal okay we
have time i guess we do yeah
i have to get this out but
gabriel and i were we have a
meeting to possibly host that show and
then nothing whoa i think you could
say who cares i've mentioned i've mentioned
on this show that i was in
the top ten or something to host
american idol you were
never said that says this no that
would be fucking insane will be really
weird it was it was because they
wanted it a duo because the the
one who was your partner it was
my old comedy partner wow and i
was so fucking broke and i was
trying to figure out what the show
was right i was like because they're
like it's based on this
the english format and it's very popular
in england um and they were like
we don't know how it's gonna do
yeah but you know it's very popular
in england at least so i got
all these like english music magazines and
they were all talking about it but
they were talking about it like everyone
knew what it was like it wasn't
like an article that said like
this is a program that would hear
it out so i just would read
these like articles about this sensation that
we're talking about it like you all
know what this is and and you
all know the players involved in sites
like joe scotto come in whatever you
do does explain pop idol so we
we went in and we we auditioned
and
and i remember divvying up the the
ah the responsibilities where i was going
to sort of drive it and my
partner was going to sort of make
jokes you know what i mean and
i was gonna riff on the show
so she goes breaks right yes is
the breaks oh no
and and we and we ace the
the first audition in front of like
the the simon guy who not sammy
cal but this the other guy got
like ah not timing the guy who
says that guy who says if you
post this part yeah somebody somebody says
gemma so i remember it being
like yours joe ah sorry hosting you
don't notice the show i think does
these days and i was so broke
and i had no money and i
think that was the summer my car
was repossessed and all this kind of
stuff no money yeah it was a
terrible combo de boers and i was
just like i need this i need
this i need this and then i
remember
getting to the final callback and looking
around the room and it was all
people who obviously were paired up and
then ryan seacrest was there by himself
and i'm like they're just going to
give it to ryan seacrest so you
knew who he was yeah yeah well
because he was he was still very
popular disc jockey town you know um
and i was like they're just going
to give it to ryan seacrest need
hosted a bunch of stuff they're just
giving it to him right yeah it's
an audition he he was auditioning yeah
but you do see auditioners you know
no no we we all went into
the room and then the second audition
just eight total shit you dan
ah the audition the audition didn't go
well and and i was just so
bombed and i was like oh my
god i need money so bad i'm
out of money you would have is
extreme no but i would i would
have been dunkelman yes what's dunkelman oh
the first guys guy i wouldn't put
that together
what's uncle menu that can't feel good
if he hears that he's not even
who
it's uncle then it hasn't good title
in any case but i got i
got very close to two and then
of course it became like a huge
sensation i'm like oh i'm so glad
because i just was wanting to do
something for the summer like there's no
way yeah for the serrano yeah that
would be crazy i remember that first
season of american idol yeah it was
only the first season where they had
dunkelman yeah and they were doing
in terrible bits yeah yeah that's some
kelly clarkson won right yeah yeah but
i mean great singers oh sure yeah
but that that was a weird i
guess i don't remember oh i remember
the show it was very short lived
they must have had that in the
u k verge that's that it was
ant and dec and that you kinda
cool they were a comedy team and
they did all these any team doing
bits on the show
show on the daily well that's nice
and then they realized no one likes
bits here and bits yeah do not
need them yeah no anyway so and
that led me to this oh yeah
she's glad oh my god oh no
well alright origin style just finish your
story is your story because that i
i at the time i wasn't really
thinking i had written that i was
going to delay the medication as long
as possible but then got to a
point where i was like time for
the epidural and then they told me
it was too late and i could
not use it so i snooze you
lou was very scared and then my
doula was like you said you want
to do this let's go and i
was like okay and
then we just did it and it
was crazy and crazy would you ever
been able to if you could have
held the baby in could you've gone
back the next day and got an
epidural i think so i think they
were just like just today and too
late but if you come like once
once it hits midnight exactly yeah yeah
fine yeah gremlins rule yeah alright look
i wanna ah on the next episode
let's maybe talk about
post us or something but we have
to take a break right now when
we come back we're gonna we're gonna
play three year yeah yeah i can
say that yeah we're gonna
yeah
a one hundred one hundred i couldn't
find it i caught a were here
one hundred guys what time do you
think it is right now huh let
me tell you so
somehow i've been sitting here the entire
episode i gained twenty one steps somehow
know you didn't like total shit you
are waving your phone around
threw it across the room i went
to go get it i can't remember
what it took before yeah i don't
know anything i certainly didn't move
do you keep track of your steps
though i don't really i just keep
track of my exercise and my caloric
intake what foods i'm eating do checking
on your heart rate
no i don't i find it interesting
for today stay one emily
i find it interesting in a week
i i would imagine like two days
from now you're never gonna look at
your heart rate ever okay my heart
rate but i will look at my
fitbit you'll look at your fitbit all
the time next time you have a
fight with mike look at your heart
rate and see what it's done tonight
i'm sitting liking next time you make
love huh oh ninety three you know
this is
in the goop i don't like that
oh the god we should host goop
we should we should oh we like
to like american idol or like say
the army team you drive it and
you were like we think this is
really important i'll be like oh so
important i forgot to think about it
that's like a bit like
some people are watching people fuck on
goop one yeah and there's idiots
hey
alright it's time for reacher shut up
this one is submitted by kelsey apple
get so close to applegate but not
so my name is close to christina
but not can i tell you a
weird christina applegate story yeah and then
tell a normal one to balance it
out okay yeah okay so this is
part of restaurant route
auto bow by the way josh is
really laughing at me i just want
people to know he's giving it to
you that's really good
see he feels like you need it
oh oh my god let's hear your
story in a better beware so i
was at chin chin waiting tables restaurant
rule waited on someone outside on the
patio i think you've told the story
already already yeah i'm not sure
is this this older guys this is
holy christian applicant in disguise and she
was just like was your secret shopping
you should use reverse white chicken that
sketch on i think you should leave
so it's so funny i wanna be
around anymore i love it oh my
god i don't know what it is
oh it's really funny um you're missing
out now i've seen it i just
don't know what it is oh the
one where the guy goes
as to a prank at the mall
and he has like that whoa yeah
yeah so so i do the whole
meal with this guy and then the
guy goes hey you wanna know some
people will deal with this guy but
today call the crazies as he's he's
like pe oh i didn't meal with
this table over there they're the worst
he's paid we've settled the bill these
tips it's over are with theirs
no more to talk about as far
as i'm concerned and be seeing each
other anymore he's what you wanna know
a secret from god i go sure
he goes you know christina applegate
oh you did okay because i'm a
dad
yeah and i go cool
hey yeah because yale gates i don't
know whether it's true or ny really
really hope it's a lie i hope
i do because we're fucking doing that
you could be so many people's dad
i will be
and who's dead realistic well i mean
like he didn't look like a scene
i'm like yeah exactly like you you
should go to adam driver and you
say hey i tell you the secret
of zen day is dead
no christina appleby
ah you named his own restaurant after
you don't know what he is
and those times a day the commies
and dirty secret i'm so proud of
our secret one of the secret i'm
very proud of twenty famous daughter to
tell her she doesn't know of a
dad
no heading out to sea i think
even said do you think she's hot
before oh no yeah i think it
was hey you wanna know a secret
to go sure he goes you know
christina applegate ago yeah you think she's
hot pico yeah because i'm a dad
that's fucking weird manner i hope it's
not actually her debt yeah i hope
he didn't say that i know he
did
id say it well
he did not spray it he didn't
know and he made a better door
than a window i have to say
sorry tell us about this feature this
feature submitted by wouldn't be freedom by
the way if i didn't tell a
story that i already know the previous
episodes shows some law we dabble get
is called bad judge remember bet santa
oh my god thanks for the censorship
sons and santos should be caring and
give toys yeah and oh
only work on december twenty fifth and
in bed saturday while he works on
december twenty four doing yeah the center
he should not smoke a cigar or
do curse words but he does all
of that and most vile santa which
crews should have called it file santa
is disgusting
they should have said if you'd like
santa don't see don't see yeah i
bet if they made bets and now
he wouldn't get the vaccine because of
cancel culture
wouldn't get the vaccine because yeah that's
what that's what that's what shannon santos
would be like now this game is
called bad judge one person i e
the judge is ill prepared for a
case they are presiding over they entered
the courtroom and have to figure out
what crime is being tried based off
an improv done by the
other to lawyer slash witness prosecutor slash
defendant etc the the people that populate
the courtroom sketch artists not helpful who
are trying to be vague so as
not to give it away but are
having realistic trial conversation though the crime
can be ridiculous gotta be really realistic
though yes it has to sound like
like authentic courtroom jargon okay got it
are you going to be the judge
the bad i don't even know i
just read the thing i feel like
i wasn't retaining it i i think
i got we've done similar things basically
you can't say directly what the judge
if the judge ever gets used too
big of words
you have to do this to get
before it's gonna go well yeah so
if you are you have to be
vague about it so if a judge
guesses oh the games oh yes and
and one of us tells the other
one what the crime yeah yeah oh
look i'll be the judge since i
think i know okay okay and then
the new guy's crime o texto crime
please don't do the crime unless you're
willing to do the ta
gold text crom can i text the
krem from those few texts that time
lauren and paul are texting each other
furiously paulo is sort of actually a
little more haphazardly tapping buttons so she's
haphazard i did my tap has my
lovely wife says hef hazard but it's
haphazard i know it is haphazard yeah
but i also heard somebody else say
it recently well if i think it's
wrong to say half as
and although the way it's spelled but
early yes it's a sin yes i'll
sin denon denon and i've never ever
hey everybody i'm going to go nothing
we got talked about the pet shop
boys on this this show more you
wanna hear a weird pet shop boys
storing yeah they went to lore what
my so usually just go to a
pet up
no paul saying no he's lying okay
it's so specific and i'm supposed to
be
or should just because i do a
specific order so you see ya let's
ride my ride was supposed to be
specific so you could talk our way
yeah or you're saying your way recipe
vague alright no we should talk about
an a vague way yeah that's right
yeah i thought you need some material
to get in sixty seconds oh you
thought i needed some mature
wait who are we going to be
um i'm i'm the person the victim
okay you're the lawyer well which lawyer
though my the i'll be the i'll
be your lawyer okay yeah but one
of maybe you guys should both be
lawyers like one's defense one's product shine
i'll be the prosecutor oh because normally
the client wouldn't say i'm the
defense meaning i'm talking about the victim
yeah you're trying to defend the thing
right okay here we go ready yes
come on in what it's open we
were already here you're the one that's
late hopes are you knocked on the
door opened it walked into the courtroom
come on are you trying to get
a judge catchphrase started because that's weird
dude am i an asshole right now
we are who's filming we're embarrassed for
dude where's my job guys i'm a
bad guy gosh i know we're on
opposite sides but that's good thanks i
thought i was pretty shot up order
in the court okay all right ah
attorneys approach the bench okay i want
a fair fair trial here okay i
want you guys
to keep everything above the belt i
want you to shake hands and let's
get it on here we go he's
trying so hard to challenge
your honor obviously you know the case
before you obviously but refresh my memory
a little bit this is a crime
that should not have happened
because should any crime happen though some
crimes should happen yes like what
abortion wait you are defending a person
who did it yeah please let me
just making sure i'm into it keep
rolling my man the defense would have
you believe
that my client committed a crime but
i say it is the the the
prosecution calls no there the prosecution you're
the brother your defense on the prosecution
okay you're defending the person yes you're
putting the burden of the crime happened
to know this doesn't make any sense
the victim you're representing the person yes
yes you're the prosecution you're the defense
nsw on the defense yeah i'm saying
you should go to jail yes okay
okay so you're defending
yes the episode have this is a
crime that shouldn't happen wait i think
this is a crime that shouldn't have
whole lot
get your shit together bro honor so
what my client is being convicted of
is not the crime i am focusing
on you know oh wait oh wait
yes i wanna hear this what do
you got this thing was so bad
that happened to my client who had
slaved for
four years to have everything that she
has to have it removed from her
in such a way oh the your
honor this is this is well burglary
we're talking about removal my client being
removed from his place of birth against
his will and placed somewhere he says
no idea okay sue
this is a kidnapping charge then essentially
kitchen and running across state lines your
honor yeah please can we focus on
the case at hand okay so that's
not that's a different case something yeah
yes it's not kidnapping yes yes i
wish we were trying that case here
today sure yeah this is this snapping
see a little bit more cut and
drives burglary then this is ah
property that was stolen yes oh what
but my point is was a property
that was stolen or was it a
honey trap to lure my client away
to get him in hot water whoa
you think that my client purposely enticed
your client to come to her home
lm and take one of her most
prized treats so this was this this
was stealing a dog's treats ooh that's
very unkind your clan a dog i
look i call them like i sees
oh wow don't try to show you
know
oh man please order in this court
if i call you a dog you're
gonna sit there and you're gonna like
it
it could be very simple it could
you always it couldn't be that your
your client did it premeditated perhaps your
client is because she is getting on
in years rep she's senile okay so
you have an old lady client who
basically was lured over to your client's
house in order to is that right
or do you have a client it
sure is it i like we all
have clients yeah
me for being confused either you act
alright i gotta take it my sustainment
was peacefully think sustaining is when you
hear what it is yeah no that
all sustained because i want to hear
my plan peacefully
sitting in her sitting room
perfect when she saw one of the
most terrifying images go past her home
this client i object to that characterization
your honor is your client rick astley
no okay
my client europe although my client will
never let you down or hurt you
never gonna run around and desert you
okay good good deny class day and
never would either okay love air
i think that someone came over to
this old lady's house right your client
went over this old lady's house that
much seems clear my client was in
the vicinity yes and what you believe
was lured over there by this possession
that was stolen i'm saying my client
your client doesn't know better your client
was supposed to be locked up to
begin with your client is a werewolf
or a dog
neither your honor he's right here way
could come over here explain your your
occupation sir
ah let talk a little more okay
this is your client a monkey he's
not oh you're oh a manager
it's very very that big xy words
that he said when he saw my
client through her window so so for
me the client so i think that's
i don't think first of all i
don't think we you speak the same
language so that's very you're what you're
saying is ridiculous locked up to the
window and
huh huh and he then proceeded to
do the heinous act that he committed
by heinous act is what it could
be described as taking someone from their
birthplace locking them in a cage and
then blaming them when they free themselves
this is king kong well that's fair
that's very flattering is it king kong
that's flattering though it's it but it's
ah an animal of sorts from another
country or an animal from another country
get it was lured over to this
old lady the old lady was taking
a shower i would have i would
imagine you mind were treated before lathering
tooth really wrinkly assed i guess you
could sing them so you're the one
who would imagine she was in the
shower you sasha
our sitting room when the sidebar your
honor i hate getting this oh my
god i can't even wait for me
and i joined the sidebar oh your
honor oh it's right checked huh sustained
i want to hear it
this is what happened that thing came
up to her window and took something
from it took oh took something from
the window okay so took took something
that my old client loved very very
much took took the ah the screen
window or two it was no screen
and she lets the bugs in
let's bug recently lets them play pea
knuckle under snow i say that my
client was not was not the willfully
stealing he was he was escaping he
had he had no idea where he
was or what he was doing stole
the the actual window like the pains
often what you share a window and
king you're saying about all something
off of the window yes a window
sill stole the sill no stove stole
a pie off the sill wasn't even
high but there was some food it's
where pie might go and yes it's
edible so stole a banana know ah
something my old client loves very much
my client had never
seen something like this before probably didn't
even always food
um because never
look you gotta give me something to
narrow down this flight you ask your
questions and we've answered that jake candies
yeah handy yes where there's a redress
i gave you with the you needed
you free know how good my client
know what was coming into this courtroom
and talk to me like that i
was gonna hold me when you can
tell exactly you're the late comer dammit
my
my client doesn't even know where there's
originals are we done now after he
scarfed them down well can you blame
him they're delicious so your client was
was taken from another country yes came
over here found these were there's originals
on the sills stole them and eat
them is that ah am i getting
this that is all true theft implies
intent i maintain my
client payroll okay
do you know what his client is
ah some sort of animal ah i
mean you are close with king kong
just giving him a lot of video
went way far away for some reason
well i first went on king kong
an ape well be a little more
specific an orangutan know around ten of
the forest
ah what other types of apes are
are a king kongs are there jane
goodall's study ah gorillas yeah yeah okay
so you're a gorilla really perked up
i'm ready to rule okay we will
rock as well i am alright here's
all i like king solomon oh boy
i want to split this baby in
half okay do you have the candy
the candy in question it's in his
diarrhea get it for me would you
to be honest you should not have
been eating that
i rule in favor of the defendant
me i don't know yes
where's your year no you're the yes
you're the defendant yeah yes i love
that to you on my way to
i love well look let's be honest
your client is not long for this
world she does xii i don't even
know if she knows i mean she
keeps saying i never well i just
buy more candy not just by ya
oh but nice little
monkey you have a great story to
tell okay yeah she's got a great
story to tell you think she's gonna
say that in between her just saying
well i never i don't know let's
find out oh okay granny when she
tells the story well
yeah i don't think i don't you
know i don't want to turn this
into a hearing on whether she's competent
to actually get awry due story objection
she'd would like to turn it into
hearing okay she can write stories yeah
let's read one of these stories there
are one hundred pages long okay let's
read one page of the first story
that she's written
oh say can you see home fire
blazing skies they desperately reg
oh this is brilliant this oh i
mean i think it's good to i
gotta publish his i look i self
publish poetry i'm a bit of a
slam poet in my spare time
i also have a vanity press
i would love to publish you old
lee when i publish that don't have
you ever heard such a thing why
publish music articles okay hold on both
good it's almost unique hear hear squeaky
toy makers come on here here
sure she'll go with you whatever yeah
don't you wanna make friends with the
gorilla no
well this is great i got a
great hot new article one hundred pages
that's gonna fill up the magazine yeah
it's not an article it's a i
mean it's obviously it's a story story
tom to atone to ether okay so
we're gonna have a double sized issue
this this month that's perfect double star
jean
zine is double stuff this month alright
get out of my court ny i
love you play bad judge wow that
was fun well we've run out of
time for my segment which is too
bad but oh well next time we'll
do that we'll do it twice next
time okay good or is it going
to be like jimmy kimmel where he's
always like bad theme and we know
of time for you today
guys ways i guess it is we're
so happy to be back we're so
happy to be here you can hear
sky if we don't have time for
you today you can hear us of
course anywhere you get your podcasts and
then also you can listen ad-free on
both stitcher premium and cbp world dot
com yeah here these episodes
ad free if you gotta do it
man sign up for one of those
things so please if you're listening to
this with ads the ad full version
please support our sponsors just like crocs
must have my crocs now that's the
song get you have my crossbow must
have my crossbow must have like cracks
now one hundred one
hundred alright let's try one last time
i got ah here we go ready
three
are you gonna do we're just gonna
say one hundred will say one hundred
ok here we go ready they're easy
to one hundred see it i would
like to submit a three-acre three three
daily mail shop in the end yeah
i know okay
a
uh